when an actor or actress first
approaches a role we use every tool at
our disposal to help us create the world
of the character
you can find valuable pieces of insight
from anything around you the script the
director your fellow actors the costume
everything
yet it's what a performer brings to the
role personally that truly forges that
character into existence
these nominees showed intelligence
curiosity and a commitment to revealing
their character's Humanity in every
aspect of their portrayals
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor and a leading role
Austin Butler Elvis
Colin Farrell the Banshees of innishin
Brendan Fraser the whale
Paul meskel after song
Bill Nye living
and the Oscar goes to
Brendan fazer
Brendan Fraser developed an interest in
acting
acting a West End performance of the
musical Oliver
so this is what the Multiverse looks
like
oh my goodness
um I thank the academy for this honor
and for our studio a24 for making such a
bold film
and I'm grateful to Darren iranovsky for
throwing me a creative lifeline and
Hauling me aboard the Good Ship the
whale
that was written by Samuel D Hunter who
is our lighthouse
gentlemen
you laid your
whale-sized hearts bare
so that we could see into your souls
like no one else could do and it is my
honor to be named alongside you in this
category
I
want to tell you that only whales can
swim at the depth of the talent of
hongchao
and
I started in this business 30 years ago
and things they didn't come easily to me
but there was a facility that I didn't
uh I didn't appreciate at the time
until it stopped
and
I just want to say thank you for this
acknowledgment
because it couldn't be done
without my cast it's it's been like it's
been like I've been on a diving
Expedition on the bottom of the ocean
and the air on the line to the surface
is on a launch being watched over by
some people in my life like my son's
Holden in Leland in Griffin I love you
Griffey my manager Joanne Colona
Jennifer plant
and my best first mate Genie
thank you again each one and all
I'm so grateful to you good night
[Applause]
[Music]